matt ryan joining us uh from atlanta how
do you feel about the season there matt
you know i'm i'm hopeful uh that that we
can get this thing going
um you know obviously with everything
that's been going on
uh this offseason and watching the other
major sports try and get up and running
uh and what happened with the marlins
the other day you know you become
skeptical but
i've been able to get my testing done uh
really the last
you know five days here at our facility
and have seen the setup that we have
i got to give our credit uh our
organization a lot of credit they have
it set up really well
uh to keep us as safe as possible i got
my little tracker on
uh in the building i'm the only one in
this room right now so i got no mask on
but
i feel good about what they've done and
i'm i'm hopeful that we'll be able to
play come september
what's the tracker so i think this
tracker is
is league mandated and so they put it on
like a wristband
yeah like a wristband and then there's
this this kind of device or whatever
that's inside of it that tells you if
you're within
six feet of anybody and so uh it starts
to kind of beat red and you can move
away but
it's also in case anybody test positive
they can go back and check the data to
see who was
uh who was around that person for an
extended period of time so they can
quarantine those
uh you know those players or coaches or
or personnel and
then test them again within 24 hours to
make sure uh everything is safe
i'm wondering about the quarterback room
is that going to be different this
season
of can you guys all be together and then
run that risk of
if one guy tests positive then everybody
else is
and what that would do to your roster be
tough
you know it would be tough if it wipes
through uh
you know one of the position groups
which in our
you know our sport can be pretty small i
mean it could really
affect uh you know really affect the
outcome of of games or or
may not even be able to play but uh you
know we're lucky
in in our building we've got a great
setup where we have tons of space
and so you know we're able to to kind of
you know
separate from each other make sure we
all got masks on and try and do
everything we can but you're right there
there is there's a lot of unknown
on uh on what and and you know
could happen but i think it's our
responsibility as
as players and you know as as citizens
of the country right to kind of
do everything we're being told to do to
try and stay as safe as possible
we're talking to matt ryan uh the
falcons quarterback what was your
reaction
to the patrick mahomes contract
i was happy for patrick
it's a good time to be a quarterback in
the nfl there's no question about it so
uh but you know he's he's been such a
dynamic player since he's come into the
league and
uh you know i think it's good for him i
think it's good for their organization
too
you know there's long-term stability
there and um
you know they know what they've gotten
him in terms of a player uh in terms of
a leader and
uh you know he's he's been unbelievable
and
i'm happy for him but explain this to me
matt maybe you're not the right guy to
ask this question to but why is it the
next quarterback
gets more than the previous quarterback
no matter what
and that next quarterback is not
necessarily better than the
previous quarterback who had the highest
salary in the league
i don't overthink it dan
i don't overthink that one i just go
with it but you don't
do you look at other salaries here and
say
well i'm better than him or he's getting
paid more me i'm better than him
i i don't you know i i think that um
everybody you know there's there's a
market there
right and you know whatever the market
dictates
um you know that's that's what it is and
so you know i've never really gotten too
hung up on it
and and we're fortunate i say that from
a place where i've been fortunate my
entire career
uh to be incredibly well compensated and
so um
but i i just it's never been something
that i've been jealous of other guys
or you know felt like other guys weren't
deserving of it i'm for everybody
uh you know making what they can make
and getting what they can get and
you know because to be honest with you
for as long as i've played you see
people who get injured at different
times our game is so
uh one play at a time that you know i'm
all four people getting what they can
get when they can get it
what was your reaction when brady signed
with the buccaneers
i was like come on man
uh no i mean i kind of
my gut was kind of telling me you know
this this could be a potential landing
spot for them
uh having played against them last year
knowing how good their defense was the
weapons that they have on offense i
thought you know this could this could
be a potential landing spot for him when
he announced he wasn't going back to new
england so
i wasn't all together too surprised
because i thought it would be a good fit
have you ever had a conversation with
him about that super bowl
uh no just he sent some text messages
after that game
and uh you know i i'm not sure i'm
i'm i'm not sure i'm still in a good
enough place to have a a
a reasonable conversation with him about
i'm not sure i'll ever be there but but
if you played golf with him
would you bring it up or would you wait
for him to bring it up
uh i i think you got to rip the band-aid
i'm at a voice in my life
uh where i found in these kind of things
i think you just gotta get it out there
and throw it out there and so yeah i
think if i were you know
having a beer with him or or playing
golf or something like that i think it'd
be like man so
why'd you have to do that why'd you have
to go there
because you know that he loves to talk
trash but i don't there's certain things
that you
are those off limits he's always
to be honest with you you know in the
passing
you know the times i've seen him in
passing or the conversations that i've
had with him he's always been super
respectful
okay uh and you know so
i don't think he needs to talk any trash
there's nothing that really needs to be
said uh what are you doing with gatorade
well i'm happy yeah to be able to uh
promote eric gilbert uh who i got to
spend time with in december and
announced when he was the uh national
football player of the year but
uh they're announcing he's the 2020 male
athlete of the year at the high school
level so
uh just you know congratulating him i've
come full circle in this spot saw him as
the football player last year
excited to see what he does at lsu and
excited for him because it's
you know it's an incredibly prestigious
award the most prestigious in high
school
uh sports because it takes into account
not only what you did on the field but
also
you know who you are as a person and
what you did into the classroom so you
know huge congratulations to him
if it wasn't boston college where were
you going
i was kind of between a couple different
places iowa purdue
and some of those schools in the big ten
but uh
boston college was was always kind of
the spot i wanted to play for whatever
reason my uncle played there i grew up
one of the you know one of the few
boston college fans there are
you know i grew up a bc fan and i've
always wanted to go there
uh just for the record you're not going
to opt out this season you are going to
play for the falcons
i'm going to play i'm already in the
building uh and all checked in and all
that stuff i guess
guys have until the third and you know i
respect that decision for for people to
make it but
uh you know i feel comfortable you know
with with playing this year
great to visit with you again good luck
uh in that division
you don't have too many uh thank god the
panthers are there
they're not very good but the saints and
buccaneers
they're going to test you a little bit
there man yeah you never know
you never know how it's going to go but
uh it's going to be a tough one this
year for sure we've got to work it out
first
thank you thank you matt great to talk
to you be safe
that's matt ryan falcons quarterback